as all battles against upper moons are
finished there is only one more battle
to be fought tonight and it will most
certainly be the toughest one ever for
demon slayers we are of course talking
about a battle against the demon lord
himself
kibutsuji
the first team of demon slayers arrives
where muzon's flesh cocoon is located
and a second group is following them
kyria immediately orders the demon
slayers to stay away from muzon until
all the hashiras arrive suddenly muzon
emerges from his flesh cocoon with a
brand new appearance his hair being far
longer and silver white due to his
accelerated aging he also has numerous
jaws all over his body with sharp white
fangs used to consume human flesh luzon
massacres dozens of demon slayers within
his vicinity as the others tried to
retreat from his location however moves
on murders and consumes all the demon
slayers and beheads the kazugare crow
that gave the orders to retreat back at
what's left at the demonstrator
headquarters kiryat commands the second
troop of demon slayers to retreat and
keep their distance away from muzon as
he'll only regain more strength and
stamina from consuming more flesh muzon
lifts tomaio's disembodied head and
mockingly points out that her drug to
turn him back into a human is not
working he then crushes tomeo's skull
and consumes her blood and sells busan
continues massacring more and more demon
slayers within his path continuing to
gain more stamina muzon knows that every
single member of the 12 kizuki was of no
use to him and that he'll slaughter the
demon slayers himself kirya completely
loses concentration and starts panicking
blaming himself for giving the wrong
orders kawina slaps kyria out of his
self-doubting situation and yells at him
to keep it together even calling him
oyokarasama she then states that the
fight isn't over yet and that he still
needs to command demon slayers this
brings back kyria's confidence and
concentration thus he commands that all
the remaining hashira must go to muzon's
location immediately along with all the
demon slayers as reinforcements
in the middle of their fight mitsuri and
obanai are the first to hear this
message obanite points out that nakeem
is not exactly harming them but stalling
them for time so the least amount of
ashira can reach musan obonah quickly
grabs mitsuri in order for both of them
to get out of the situation they're in
quickly realizing this nakeem uses her
blood demon art in order to teleport
muzan to tandro and giu's location
tantrosis moves on in the flesh and rage
immediately fuels inside of him while
giul tells him to calm down muzon calls
them incredibly persistent which sickens
him to his core with that being said he
says that those who are alive should be
grateful for being alive and should stop
wasting their lives on vengeance tantro
calmly points out that muzon is a being
that does not deserve to even exist he
thinks to himself that muzan cannot die
from decapitation and tries to figure
out a way how they can expose him to the
sun the problem is that they have no
idea how to bring muzon out of the
infinity castle muzon immediately
transforms his arms into long spiked
tentacles that function like whips and
flails them at both tondro and giu guyu
uses water breathing dead calm in order
to repel the attacks but still gets cut
tundra notes that muzan's attacks are
unbelievable in both destructive power
and lethality as he is only dodging by
instinct alone however he keeps his
tenacity going and attempts to go
through muzon's whips in order to harm
him in some way just when he got within
the striking distance one of muzon's
arms cuts tondro's right eye knocking
him to the ground before muzon can
finish him off gu rushes in and saves
him telling him that slashing muzon is
absolutely pointless since his strength
is incomparable to anything they face so
far who's on scoffs at the demon
slayer's efforts stalling the battle
against him is pointless as the sun
can't penetrate the walls of the
infinity castle he then asks them if 3
hashira is really enough to defeat him
this confuses guil and tanjro as muzon
specifies that both mitsuri and obanai
were killed by nakeem he saw this
through her eyes
muzan keeps attacking the two demon
slayers with his whips pushing them into
a corner suddenly the love hashira
mitsuri drops through the ceiling and
stops muzon's assault missouri is sure
that her attack must have harmed muzon
in some way but to her shock the demon
king is completely unscathed obani also
appears and helps tangero get back up
tondro is relieved to see both of them
still alive while muzon is utterly
confused he shouts nakeem's name in fury
and demands to know what she is doing
however yushiro responds revealing that
nikima is defeated and that he is now in
control of the infinity castle while
muzon tries to fight him back giu takes
the opportunity to attack muzong along
with obanai this distracts muzan as he
doesn't know whether to fight against
teshira or to continue battling yushiro
the floor where the main battle is
taking place suddenly opens making
everyone fall muzon lifts his right arm
and closes his fist crushing nakeem's
head because of this the entire infinity
castle starts to collapse flinging
everyone in all directions tonjero opens
his eyes and sees the night sky
realizing that they are back in the real
world however they landed on a city
street with many innocent civilians
kazukai crow tells everyone that an hour
and a half is left until dawn breaks and
that their only chance is to keep moose
on there until then as the hashira and
all other demon slayers make out of the
rebel muzon unleashes a large shockwave
to push all the rubble off him he then
states oh so you are planning on keeping
me here until dawn huh we'll go right on
ahead if you can
the final battle begins with ashira
dodging luzon's attacks and retaliating
with their respective breathing forms
obanai was able to slash muzon's neck
but to no avail as the cut regenerates
instantaneously as the hasheras are
confused muzan takes this opportunity to
strike and kill all the hashira just as
he is about to land his attacks dozens
of demon slayers come forth and
sacrifice themselves to save the hashira
while the demon slayers keep sacrificing
themselves one of them tells the others
to protect the hashera with their lives
as the hashira always protected them
mitsuri cries and yells at the demon's
lairs to stop as there have been too
many casualties already tundra not
wanting any more demon slayers to die
stands up and tries to run back into the
fight but stumbles and falls coughing
out large amounts of blood while all
this is happening muzon comments that
those who are wounded by him are
destined to die as he points to tonjaro
slowly dying with his eye wound turning
into a large clump of flesh while tantra
lies dying nezuko stands up from her
medical bed and starts running toward
the battlefield curia at once orders
everyone to get nezuko back but someone
with a swollen hand softly touches his
shoulder that being his father kagaya
ubu yashiki with his soft voice kagaya
requests his only son to let nezuku go
and that she'll be fine
back on the battlefield with tantro
coming closer to death the hashira get
repeatedly slashed and cut by muzon's
attacks mitsuri gets the worst of
muzon's barrage and just as she was
about to get impaled by one of muzon's
armed tentacles a sudden impact destroys
that tentacle saving mitsuri it certain
turns out to be gyome coming to
everyone's surprise especially the demon
kings as muzon comments to himself that
gyome is one of the demon slayers who
defeated his right-hand man kokushibo
sonomi appears behind the demon lord and
slices him vertically as muzan
regenerates the wind hashira throws
multiple glasses of oil at the demon
lord sanami then lights a match and
tosses it at the demon lighting him
entirely on fire muzan's attacks keep
getting fiercer adding more pressure on
the hashira gyome even points out that
due to him not being able to access the
transparent world it is nearly a gamble
to be able to dodge the demon king's
attacks mitsuri however is in the worst
position only being able to dodge purely
by instinct and luck alone this deeply
impacts the resolve on being able to
help her fellow hashira defeat muzon she
plans on trying to get behind the ladder
and twist his arms behind his back in
order to stall for time and help the
others land some hits on the demon lord
even if she sacrifices her life doing so
while she evaluates her plan she fails
to see the incoming attack and the
entire left side of her body gets
slashed obani immediately comes to her
aid and carries her out of the
battlefield mitsuri however still tries
to get up and convince obanai to let her
continue fighting saying that she won't
be a burden to anyone obenai quickly
rejects telling her that it's okay and
she has done enough although when i
quickly sprints back into the
battlefield mitsui bursts into tears and
begs overnight to not die
as giu attempts to cut off one of
muzon's arms the attack launches his
broken blade off of his hands showcasing
his grip waning as a result of the
poison from the former's attacks before
one of muzon's whips slashes and kills
giulio both obani and gyomi intervene
and stop the attack sonemy throws giu's
nichiren sword back at him yelling at
the ladder to focus or he will be killed
being ashamed of himself or letting his
fellow heshira down giu picks up the
sword and unleashes water breathing at
the demon king even muzon acknowledges
demon slayer's resilience but knows that
it is of no use as this poison will kill
them all long before dawn as there is
still an hour and fourteen minutes of
the night time left suddenly tomeo's cat
enters the battlefield carrying four
vials of mysterious liquid as the vials
are ejected into the heshira the
symptoms of muzon's poison are seemingly
gone this greatly angers and frustrates
muzan as even after death tamiya
continues to be a nuisance to him obani
comments to himself that his
contribution in this fight is minimal as
he believes that he didn't land any
crucial blows on the demon lord while
saying this he remembers that when
someone is on the verge of death they
can release explosive energy he compares
himself to moichiro who was able to
change the color of his blade solely
with a powerful grip he accepts that one
must grow past their own limits to
defend everyone and with this he grips
his nichiren sword as strong as he can
and manages to turn it bright red as
obanized demon's lair mark also awakens
sonomy yells to alert the former that
one of muzon's tentacles is coming
straight for him giu attempts to save
him but is too late however obani is
somehow up in the air dodging muzon's
attack the demon lord whips one of his
arms tentacles at the serpent ashira but
he somehow dodges it again adding to
muzon's confusion the arm that he
attacked obani with gets cut off
seemingly with no one around the same
cut happens again with muzan realizing
that there must be someone else here he
just can't see them muzon lashes his
website what seems like thin air but
soon appears to be zenetsu inosuke and
canal wearing invisibility blindfolds
that yushiro gave them obani manages to
cut both of muzon's arms and sonemi
realizes that his regeneration speed is
slowing down due to being cut with a red
nichiren sword canal and zenitsu grab
another blindfold and become invisible
again attacking the demon lord with
their respective breathing forms gyome
is thankful that obama's blade is still
shining red and that the demon slayer
core's manpower has increased now that
canal zenitsu and inosuke joined the
fight with this happening he has enough
time to clash his axe and spiked flail
together turning them both bright red
and demolishing a part of muzon's torso
with his flail sonomi quickly alerts giu
and strikes the ladder's sword with his
own turning both their blades bright red
as well kazugai crow informs everyone
that there is one hour and three minutes
left until dawn with sanhemi saying that
that is more than enough time to rip the
demon king to shreds
meanwhile yushiro injects tantra with
another dose of antidote with morata
concerned if he has injected too much
suddenly tantros pulse comes back and he
regains consciousness back on the
battlefield there is still hope as
everyone is seemingly overpowering muzon
at the moment with enough time to fully
concentrate gilmay tries to re-enter the
transparent world he succeeds and
visualizes multiple hearts and brains
throughout the demon lord's body despite
the overall complexity of those organs
the demon lord was still able to create
multiple hearts and brains thus
explaining him being able to survive
decapitation so easily along with this
they do not have a fixed location as
they always move around making them
incredibly difficult to hit suddenly
muzon's tentacles go wild and he
performs his special attack knocking all
demon slayers into nearby buildings all
demon slayers are now fatally wounded
and unconscious and there is no one to
stop muzan from escaping with still
around an hour until done after everyone
is knocked down canal remains the sole
fighter on the battlefield as the demon
lord walks toward her she tries to stand
up but she has no strength left as she
prepares herself for the incoming attack
tondero suddenly appears cutting both of
muzon's arms with his son breathing as
tanjoro brings canal over to goto he
apologizes for being late and requests
kakushi to take care of her tantro looks
at muzon and the two converse with the
latter being abhorred by tanjaro's
wounded appearance asking him who is the
real demon here the demon slayer enraged
at his allies injuries calls on the
demon king to end their long-standing
feud tanjuro reflects on his memories
and visions that he received when he was
asleep noting that now that he has seen
the actual sun breathing from yorichi
himself he can perform it on a much
higher level than before he thanks
yorishi for saving his ancestor and for
passing down the sun breathing to him he
realizes that the 12 forms of the sun
breathing are all connected to each
other and he is determined to keep using
all of them repeatedly to stall muzon
until dawn although tandro still doubts
his own abilities he steals his resolve
recalling rangoku's words to him to set
his heart ablaze with this he engages
his nemesis with the legendary breathing
style as tonjiro approaches he notices
muzon's new tendrils realizing that the
demon's shape-shifting abilities led to
the defeat of the heshira and his
friends meanwhile enraged muzon attacks
the advancing demon slayer and sees the
ghost of the mythical yurishi in the
young boy despite muzon's whip-slicing
tantro the latter shrugs off the attacks
retaliating with sun breathing dance
raging sun and fire wheel consecutively
as tantro begins using the legendary
13th form muzon comments that creatures
who catch a glimpse of death become even
more tenacious in reaching their goal in
order to avoid death he knows that one
must open the door of strength and
perception that are unnecessary during
their regular life with tangero turning
his nichiren sword bright red he has
opened that door as well
tangero continues engaging the demon
king with sun breathing dragon sun halo
head dance and fire wheel commenting to
himself that he has connected six out of
twelve forms tanjaro comments to himself
that his own brain and heart are
spinning while his lungs are being
pummeled and his limbs are in so much
agony that they're almost being torn
completely off as there is less than an
hour left until done tondro continues to
tell himself to focus and not think
about anything else except performing
the techniques he continues the 13th
form performing sun breathing fake
rainbow and burning bones summer sun
muzon realizes that the accuracy of the
demon slayer's techniques is fading
along with his niturian sword soon
turning to normal however even though
tantro is getting weaker and weaker he
is still managing to dodge all of
muzon's attacks this greatly confuses
the demon lord estandro's movements are
lackluster and are nowhere near their
peak due to poison uzone just can't seem
to understand why he can't kill a lone
demon slayer who is deeply burdened with
fatigue muzon suddenly realizes that he
is the one who is slow as this
one-on-one duel would certainly not have
lasted this long if he was in his usual
state after muzon finally figures out
that he has aged over nine millennia
tandro suddenly uses sun breathing solar
heat haze followed by five more sun
breathing forms muzon angrily shouts
towards the demon's lair to stop jumping
all over the place only for the latter
to continue and perform the remaining
six forms with that he has successfully
linked all 12 forms and has done the
legendary 13th form he tells himself to
keep doing the same thing only faster
and more accurately non-stop until dawn
breaks
on the other side of the battlefield
yushiro and mirada quickly give the
other demon slayer's serum to muzon's
poison yushiro himself works on healing
gyome noticing that his destroyed leg is
in a really bad shape he then prays to
tamayo to protect tandro as much as
possible the young demon slayer notes
that in order to increase the
effectiveness of all 12 techniques to
their maximum he must aim specifically
for each of muzon's vital organs saying
so he attempts to re-enter the
transparent world in order to locate
their location but it's unsuccessful due
to not having sufficient oxygen he then
tries to use his sense of smell in order
to locate the organs but soon loses his
footing and is open to one of the demon
king's whips however someone saves
tantro from his impending doom with
muzon's attacks hitting the building
behind tondro completely leveling it
tonjero remembers a familiar scent and
regains his senses and he recognizes the
figure that saved him it's obani iguro
with happiness he shouts a guru's name
but that happiness soon turns into shock
as he sees his scarred face as muzon
continues attacking the duo tantro says
that he will help iguru but the hashira
refuses by saying that he is pretty much
already blind in his right eye and that
he already has kabura maru his pet snake
to help him as igoro lets tanjaro go the
demon king approaches and unleashes a
massive attack that completely
obliterates an entire chunk of a
building suddenly tundra spots muzon's
body changing revealing numerous old
scars all over his body which he
surmised to be from yurichi's attacks
which scarred him on a cellular level
tangero then realizes that those scars
indirectly show them where to strike
muzon to deal the most damage seeing the
scars himself muzon reminisces his
encounter with yurishi with great
displeasure remarking that he looked
weak and yet his attacks would wound his
body to the point it would not heal even
after a millennium causing him to
ironically call yurichi the real monster
the kazoo guy crow announces that there
are 40 minutes left before dawn causing
muzon to suddenly flee to which igoro
remarks that muzon unlike a samurai who
has pride is a living thing that would
do anything to cling on to his own life
as the demon king makes his escape he
tramples on the corpses of the fallen
demon slayers that he killed which
causes tangero to tear up in anger and
fling their swords at his body to
muzon's annoyance iguru then appears
behind muzon and pierces his body with
his nichiren sword with this the duo
continues driving muzon into a corner
and leaves him no room to escape with 35
minutes left before the sun rises muzan
attempts to split himself into hundreds
of pieces to escape but he soon realizes
that he can't which he attributes to
tomeo's drug just then tamio's memory
appears in muzon's mind mocking him by
saying that the death that he has feared
for so long is now right in front of him
she continues by saying that just as
muzon would do anything to live she and
her allies would do anything to kill him
muzon suddenly stops moving and shapes
his torso into a massive mouth he then
unleashes a giant shockwave-like attack
that connects with both tundra and
obanai rendering them unable to breathe
momentarily it is then revealed that
there are 25 minutes left before dawn as
muzan walks away enosuke who just
regained consciousness rushes to
intercept him trembling inosuke states
that gyome lost his leg giu lost his arm
and all the corpses around them are the
buddies he shared a meal with he then
demands that muzan give back the lives
he took or he will die a million times
to make up for it annoyed moves on
attacks enosuke and lands a surprise
attack from below by extending his
transfigured arm into the ground
suddenly zenetsu arrives and slashes
muzon's arm to frianosuke telling him to
pull it together the demon king then
pushes zinitsu against a building with
his elongated arm which inosuke slashes
causing him to be hurled towards another
building tonjiro realizes that a bright
rednecheren sword may be able to nullify
the effect of muzon's blood demon art on
his nervous system and plans to stab
himself with it at the same time muzon
is unnervated unable to even lift his
own arms up he then gets exasperated
seeing xeno2 getting back up again
commenting that no matter how much he
crushes them they won't die as an oscar
continues to overwhelm the demon king
with beast breathing zenitsu comes in
with thunderbreathing godspeed thinking
to himself that he has the strength for
only one more attack with him saying
that he utilizes the thunder breathing
seventh form flaming thunder god which
slashes muzon across his torso mosque
barges in with a few different beasts
breathing forms but muzon stops his
barrage with the shockwave technique and
attempts to kill him thankfully tonjiro
saves nine okay from muzon's attack
using sun breathing burning bones summer
sun zenith tries to stand up and help
his comrades but doesn't have any
strength left to do so with that he begs
the spirit of his master jigoro to give
him strength one last time his eyes turn
white and he performs thunder breathing
first form thunderclap and flash seeing
this tondro and inosuke also attack
luzon with their respective breathing
techniques three boys work together and
with their combined strength they manage
to push muzon into a corner as tantro
can't unleash any more techniques he
resolves to hold muzon down until
sunrise the demon king tries to slash
and stab the young boy with his arm
tentacles but his left arm gets grabbed
by mitsuri shedding tears she yells at
tanza to cut his arm while she is
holding it which the boy does sonomy
then appears cutting muzon's right arm
clean off with his wind breathing with
both his arms gone the demon king's face
and torso split apart vertically
exposing huge jaws and teeth as he tries
to consume tangero however oboney gets
in front of tantro in the nick of time
and shields him from muzon's jaws sonomy
shouts to everyone to hold on just a
little bit longer as dawn arrives muzon
is terrified and he unleashes his
shockwave technique one final time
knocking everyone back except for tanjro
whose entire left arm gets torn off by
the attack
despite the chaos that's happening
tonjro keeps holding onto his blade as
hard as he possibly can in order to turn
it bright red by him saying when goku's
words again set your heart ablaze
miraculously giyu comes to tonjro's aid
and with his remaining hand grabs a hold
of tonjro's nature and sword as well
with the might of both demon slayers the
blade successfully becomes bright red as
this happens muzon coughs out blood and
with the sun shining more and more busan
realizes that his only chance to survive
is to protect himself with a mass of
flesh doing so his body expands in all
directions turning him into a giant
demonic baby to everyone's shock the
giant infant absorbs tondro into its
body and crawls around the streets to
get to safety curious shouts and begs
demon slayers to stop the demon king
from entering the shade everyone tries
as hard as they can throwing bookshelves
and driving cars into him a dozen or
more kakushi push a bus in order to
block the infant from taking shelter
from the sun as the baby tries to topple
over the bus and smash the kokushi with
its hand sometimes he leaps into the air
and unleashes wind breathing chopping
off the infant's hand clean off he
cusses at the demonic infant begging him
to turn to dust already just as the
infant was about to topple the bus over
an iron chain wraps around its neck
pulling it away from the bus giulio
sanemi and obani all use various
breathing techniques to try and slow
down the giant infant however despite
all their combined attacks on the demon
king it does not stop him from burrowing
into the ground from inside muzon's body
tandro continues to grip his nature and
sword as hard as he can maintaining its
bright red color due to this the infant
regurgitates a lot of blood from its
mouth stopping it from digging any
deeper into the ground being unable to
escape the sun in any way the demonic
infant wails and balls as it continues
to disintegrate with this the demon lord
muzan kibusuji is finally dead and
defeated forever click on this video
where we explained what would happen if
all hashira turned into demons